Et tous les scientifiques...
(Rires)
rient toujours quand je dis ça,
parce que l'écriture n'est jamais simple.
C'est si dur ; on s'arrache toujours les cheveux,
en essayant de trouver l'idée à un million de dollars.
Mais j'ai réalisé que j'arrivais à écrire
parce que j'étais capable
de me concentrer et de maintenir mon attention
plus longtemps qu'auparavant.
Et ma mémoire à long terme - ce que j'étudiais dans mon laboratoire -
semblait être meilleure.
Et c'est là que j'ai fait le lien.
Peut-être que tout l'entraînement physique que j'avais inclus dans ma vie
changeait mon cerveau.
J'avais peut-être mené une expérience sur moi-même sans le savoir.
Étant une scientifique curieuse,
j'ai été voir dans les livres ce que je pouvais trouver
sur les effets connus de l'exercice sur le cerveau.
Et j'ai trouvé une littérature excitante et en pleine expansion,
qui, en gros, décrivait tout ce que j'avais remarqué en moi-même.
Meilleure humeur, plus d'énergie, meilleure mémoire, meilleure attention.
Plus j'en apprenais,
plus je comprenais à quel point faire de l'exercice était formidable.
Ce qui m'a finalement conduite à cette grande décision :
changer complètement mon sujet de recherche.
Et après plusieurs années à vraiment me concentrer sur cette question,
j'en suis arrivée à cette conclusion :
l'exercice est la chose la plus transformatrice
que vous puissiez faire pour votre cerveau
et ce pour les trois raisons suivantes.
Un : il a des effets immédiats sur votre cerveau.
Une seule séance de sport
augmentera immédiatement les taux de neurotransmetteurs
comme la dopamine, la sérotonine et la noradrénaline.
Cela va améliorer votre humeur juste après l'exercice,
exactement ce que je ressentais.
Mon labo a montré qu'une seule séance de sport
peut améliorer votre capacité à vous concentrer
et cette amélioration va durer au moins deux heures.
Et les études ont montré
qu'une séance de sport améliorera votre temps de réaction,
ce qui veut dire en gros
que vous serez plus rapide à rattraper la tasse de café
qui tombera du comptoir,
ce qui est très, très important.
(Rires)
Mais ces effets immédiats sont éphémères, ils vous aident juste après.
Vous n'avez qu'à faire comme moi,
changer votre régime sportif, augmenter vos capacités respiratoires,
pour en avoir les effets à long terme.
Et ces effets dureront longtemps
car l'exercice modifie en fait l'anatomie du cerveau
ainsi que sa physiologie et son fonctionnement.
Commençons par ma région du cerveau favorite : l'hippocampe.
L'hippocampe...
En fait, l'exercice produit des cellules neuronales nouvelles,
dans l'hippocampe, ce qui augmente son volume,
ainsi que votre mémoire à long terme, d'accord ?
Que ce soit pour vous ou pour moi.
Deux : la découverte la plus courante dans les études de neurosciences,
sur les effets à long terme de l'exercice,
est l'amélioration de l'attention, qui dépend de votre cortex préfrontal.
Vous aurez non seulement une meilleure concentration
mais aussi une augmentation du volume de l'hippocampe.
Et finalement, vous n'avez pas seulement des effets immédiats sur l'humeur
mais des effets à long terme,
une augmentation à long terme
de ces neurotransmetteurs de la bonne humeur.
Mais en réalité, la chose la plus transformatrice de l'exercice
est son effet protecteur sur le cerveau.
Vous pouvez vous représenter le cerveau comme un muscle.
Plus vous l'entraînez,
plus votre hippocampe et votre cortex deviennent gros et forts.
Pourquoi est-ce important ?
Parce que le cortex préfrontal et l'hippocampe
sont les deux zones les plus susceptibles de subir des maladies neurodégénératives
et une baisse cognitive liée au vieillissement.
Faire de l'exercice tout au long de votre vie
ne va pas vous guérir de la démence ou d'Alzheimer
mais vous allez créer
une hippocampe et un cortex préfrontal plus forts et plus gros,
ce qui demandera plus de temps à ces maladies pour avoir un effet.
Vous pouvez donc imaginer l'exercice
comme une assurance vie pour votre cerveau, d'accord ?
C'est même mieux car c'est gratuit.
C'est normalement là que tout le monde se dit :
« Ça a l'air super-intéressant, Wendy,
mais je voudrais savoir un truc :
quel est le minimum à faire pour avoir tous ces changements ? »
(Rires)
Je vais donc vous donner la réponse à cette question.
D'abord, bonne nouvelle : pas besoin de devenir triathlète pour en bénéficier.
En gros, il vous faut faire de l'exercice trois à quatre fois par semaine,
une séance doit faire minimum 30 minutes
et il faut faire des exercices aérobies,
qui augmentent votre rythme cardiaque.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'aller à la salle de sport
et de payer très cher.
Faites un tour du pâté de maisons.
Prenez les escaliers.
Et passer l'aspirateur est aussi bon qu'un cours d'aérobic
dispensé par la salle de sport.
Je suis passée de pionnière de la mémoire
à exploratrice d'exercices physiques.
En partant du fonctionnement le plus intime du cerveau
jusqu'à essayer de comprendre comment l'exercice améliore le cerveau,
mon but de recherche est maintenant
d'aller au-delà de ces quantités que je vous ai indiquées -
3 à 4 fois par semaine, 30 minutes.
Je veux comprendre la prescription d'exercice optimale
pour vous, à votre âge, avec votre condition physique,
avec vos antécédents génétiques,
pour maximiser les effets de l'exercice aujourd'hui
et aussi améliorer votre cerveau, le protéger du mieux possible,
pour le reste de votre vie.
C'est une chose de parler d'exercice, c'en est une autre de le faire.
Je vais donc invoquer mon pouvoir de prof certifiée
pour vous demander de vous lever.
(Rires)
Nous allons faire une minute d'exercice.
Il vous suffit de faire comme moi, de dire comme moi
et faites attention à ne pas frapper votre voisin, d'accord ?
Musique !
(Musique rythmée)
Cinq, six, sept, huit, droite, gauche, droite, gauche.
Dites : « Je suis forte maintenant. »
Je ne vous entends pas.
Public : Je suis forte maintenant.
Wendy Suzuki : Mesdames, je suis forte comme Wonder Woman.
Je veux vous entendre !
Public : Je suis forte comme Wonder Woman.
WS: Maintenant : uppercut, droite et gauche.
Je suis inspirée. A vous !
Public : Je suis inspirée.
WS: Dernier : en bas, à droite, à gauche, à droite, à gauche.
Je suis en feu maintenant ! A vous !
Public : Je suis en feu maintenant !
WS: Terminé ! Bravo ! Bon travail !
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Je vais vous laisser sur cette pensée :
faire de l'exercice
ne vous donnera pas seulement une vie plus joyeuse, plus protectrice aujourd'hui
mais protègera votre cerveau de maladies incurables.
Et ainsi, cela changera votre trajectoire de vie
de manière positive.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.